[Music]
there's a heavy theme of creator and
creative and record morning you brought
me into this world the suffering
abomination tortured by the duality of
its being I crafted the guy that created
the planet you're standing on yeah and I
made the Stars it became the carbon in
your mother's ovaries I didn't ask you
before that is a fun thing for me the
idea is we have got research for meaning
and we think of that as the highest
thought we could have who made me and
I'm going to make other things what is
my purpose you pass butter oh my god
yeah welcome to the clubhouse like
Campbell called
God an impersonal cosmic force that's
the most terrifying thing about it
it doesn't give a [ __ ] about you Rick is
the seam between God and man so what do
you think get out Jerry wants to be a
good father he wants to be macho he
wants to be rich he wants to be a
provider and keeps being told by the
universe Rick represents that's a stupid
goal that will always fail because
trying it means you've already failed
some people just can't handle the truth
especially dummies like me does he have
it better off I mean I think so like at
the end of the unity episode one
character who can do anything he wants
and whose ex-girlfriend
and a billion redhead goes into the
garage tries to kill himself and only
fails because he's so drunk he can't
pull it off and the other character is
very happy to have his weed whacker back
and trimming his driveway removing the
weeds what about the reality we love
behind what about the reality where
Hitler cured cancer morning the answer
is don't think about it
do I agree with Rick that nothing means
anything no I like not because the
knowledge that nothing matters while
accurate gets you nowhere the planet is
dying the Sun is exploding universe is
cooling nothing's going to matter the
further back you poll the more that
truth will endure but when you zoom in
on earth when you zoom into a family
when you zoom into a human brain and a
childhood experience you see all these
things would matter we have this
bleeding chance to participate in an
illusion called I love my girlfriend I
love my dog how is that not better it's
a real treat to be raised by parents
that force themselves to be together
instead of being happy knowing the truth
which is that nothing matters and
actually save you in those moments
nobody exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere everybody's going to die come
watch TV once you get through that
terrifying threshold accepting that then
every place at the center of the
universe and every moment is the most
important moment and everything is
remaining of life
[Music]
the genius please
hey everybody new Rick and Morty promo
probably one of the more hardcore ones
they've released but Rick and Morty is
all about deep ideas and I love the way
the Dan Harmon is like no I do not agree
with Rick that life has no meaning even
by his own assertion jerry has it better
because he's the dummy because he's all
about this false idea of machismo being
this provider in cut 2 season 3 episode
1 that goal has gotten him divorced from
Beth we're going to take a break so it
seems like they're going full-blown
divorced this season we'll see if they
walk that back in episode 2 and I am
doing a new round of the giveaway it's
for two imax gift certificates all you
have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but the funny thing about that is
that his character almost doesn't accept
situations like that some people just
can't handle the truth like he says so
it's almost like this show is saying
that he's going to go off be sad for a
little while but he'll continue to be
happy refusing to accept the reality of
the situation and will Kramer himself
into something even better the way he
fell into all those promotions at the
beginning of the episode I've already
been promoted a couple times like he
walks into breakfast at the beginning of
the episode I just got my six promotion
this week and I still don't know what I
do Gary is definitely the luckiest
character on that show
I like how Morty's also kind of slowly
figuring it out himself - everybody's
gonna die come watch some TV
almost like Dan Harmon is just telling
that to everybody from the writers room
the world is spinning out of control
everybody just take it easy
and then Rick on the other side of that
is so hardcore that God doesn't exist
that none of these things are real that
he's ready to end himself even though
he's the most powerful character in the
universe so let me know whether you
agree or disagree with those deep
thoughts that Dan Harmon is putting out
there but in happier news the Rick
mobile is traveling around the United
States so if you live in the United
States you have a chance to go buy some
exclusive merchandise but it might show
up in their online store right now as
I'm posting this they're in Kansas City
it looks like the tour's going to end
October 8th so
every day or every couple days they go
to a new city so there's a pretty good
chance that you'll be able to get some
stuff but like looking at the map here
just if you're wondering when they're
coming to your state you can guess
they're heading left even though the car
is pointed right that's the wrong way
they're actually headed the other way so
they're headed back towards California
then they'll circle back around so the
tour doesn't end in New York till
October so there's still plenty of
opportunities to tell them to shut up
and take my money they don't have any
new information about when episode two
is going to drop but right now it seems
like either really late June early July
just because they've been so quiet about
new material so I'm expecting a couple
more promos like this but leave all your
requests for Rick and Morty videos in
the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner patty boy 17 please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
Rick and Morty what you wait for that
you can click here to watch Justin Royal
and get crazy drunk while he tries to
read his lines and you can click here
for more season 3 videos thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]